today's video is sponsored by surf shark
today's topic
our favorite boy darius m uh now that
legal proceedings will be starting in
the near future we decided we would
cover more of his videos
hey there is this video is going to be
about
a woman being controlled by her emotions
continue to take the red pill it is
paramount you must do it
don't skip a day a red pill a day keeps
the
child support alimony and the court
system away
due to their phones and dating apps and
social media platforms
they can hook up with any guy they have
the freedom to roam about
remember girls just want to have fun
all it takes is for your woman to be out
and about
at the grocery store pumping gas
she meets a guy and he says the right
words to her
gives her the butterflies
it's an unfortunate truth it's
uncomfortable
women live in the moment and now
your woman is bent over on another man's
couch
getting rammed
who's going to bring her the most
excitement that's what she wants
all it takes is for her to go out that
door
give you a kiss goodbye and now she's
single
she's always single you need a hug poor
thing
it's just poor thing pal i was like oh
this guy is this this guy's that
but i really feel i really feel bad for
you
it must be hard being you you know it's
hard seeing women that way and then
having to race two of them yeah
when people say you're able why you
singles because every woman is single
you can't be in a relationship with a
woman who could be pumping gas
and then the dude comes in now he's
pumping her
i saw you talking to that girl you
trying to [ __ ] it's the same thing
why you keep on answering your phones
who the hell
is mom that's my mom you're lying
are you man of trash today's segment
is going to be about girls night out
what they do
and what this means first of all they go
in packs four to five or even maybe
even more i'm glad you understand what
girls plural
means yes girls night out means they go
in a group
i'm glad you've done the math darius
they go to clubs or bars or different
events
just to uh wreak havoc and cause chaos
[Applause]
oh
wow oh wow to be hoarse
they go out there for attention you
think
guys don't too with the blings with the
popping champagne what you thinking we
just want to be with
no we just want to be with us
gentlemen's right here we're going to
have a discussion
popping that champagne that moet that
dawn p what do you think
they go to to a club or a bar with their
with their uh the pack of [ __ ]
and you know what's crazy about hearing
his language and how he talks about
women
he's like he's got two daughters
yes what are the odds god was like this
is what i'm gonna give you
yo god got a sense of humor that's funny
what they do is
they get in the clubs for free or five
to ten dollars why men have to pay forty
to fifty dollars to get in
and the reason for that is because they
wanna get more women more women there
more men more men more spending that's
it
if you guys weren't so thirsty and
desperate for ladies
they wouldn't be paying ladies to go to
clubs more the reason why women get paid
to go to clubs more
or they don't have to pay as much is
because they win by having more ladies
that's it do i think it's fair no do i
think it's right no
but at the same time it's men's fault
for the same reason you got
the reason why you got to pay for only
fans default man
you've been sending pics out there uh
plummeting
the pick industry right they could have
been asking and paying for
picks no some of you degeneres sent
picks for free
then you the the market plummet and what
happened
it's just easy to have it's just
available and wherever you see
pics and now we could we could we're
gonna have a business with that
okay you know only mams
then men have to pay a coat check for 10
on top of that you got to go by the
drinks so you're telling me
that's a that's a good investment for a
good four hours
uh worth of entertainment that's like a
that's a light bill for me that's my
cable bill
then don't go
or choose better spots i don't spend
nearly as much when i go up
so i don't know why you paying that much
maybe you need some better discipline
what you're finding it's not an
obligation
it's not an obligation if if you want to
go to the club then and it's not for the
ladies
obviously as you call them
then you don't need to pay all that
money right
you could go anywhere a little bar have
your beer and chill
no confusion there's no code checks i'm
confused
he disparages the woman he calls him
terrible yeah he calls him the worst
yeah
but then why are you going to the club
if you don't want to be around these
people that's what i'm saying
go to a bar and be with your homies you
know what i'm saying today's video is
sponsored by surf shark vpn
so vpn is basically an application or
web extension that you could use on your
web browser or on your internet
to mask your ip address basically hiding
your location
from whatever website you're interacting
with now you might think
why would i want to hide where i'm at it
doesn't matter well unfortunately there
are places that block you based off of
your ip address
and so if you're trying to view online
content the online so download certain
things
based off where you live those things
could be restricted
now i like watching tv shows feel me
sometimes they're foreign
feel me and when that happens
basically i use a vpn to be able to
bypass that so i can watch what i want
to watch because i feel like the
internet's at its best
when everything's accessible if you use
promo code abba and preach
you get 83 off plus three months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's barriers
you deserve to go wherever you'd like to
go i'm not going out there
just to get rejected about by land wells
or single mothers
no no you get rejected because you're
undesirable maybe if you knew how to
talk to people
or you had some game then you wouldn't
have this issue oh you wouldn't be so
hurt
you don't know what happened bro you're
referring to all them as land whales
maybe if you lived in the city or i
don't know where you live
right where there's attracted ladies you
wouldn't say that that's
that's a you problem that's a you
problem man you have you seem to have so
little confidence and game to me that's
just crazy to me that you you act like
this coach who knows it all it's like
bruh
just because you can't pull doesn't mean
other people can't pull
i remember but because you're meeting
land whales or getting rejected by
ugly women oh they're the they're the
problem no it's because
you're unlikable and judging by your
attitude in these videos and the way you
talk to please
i'm not surprised that's the one that
came to you hefner one day he's like yo
damn who how the hell did you get all
damn [ __ ] and there was girls next to
him he's like well first of all i don't
call him [ __ ]
i mean if you had a spectrum he's like
on the opposite end of like that
red-haired feminist
who just sprints uh excuse me excuse me
i'm not done talking
women hold up half the sky it's like all
right probably we get it
he's the opposite end of that spectrum
it's just like
everything you hear and i'm like bro
you're raising daughters
yeah and you talk that way about all
women
every woman is single they're all just
waiting to get
pumped ugh you know there's this idea
like promiscuity is like crazy right now
sue the roof
do you know what the average is the
average amount of partners that most
people have
i think for women it was like seven
you know what it is for guys it's like
eight
imagine being in your like 30s or
whatever
you've been with seven or eight people
now of course
it's just scale some people be with more
others have been with way less
but people act like everyone's just
every weekend
let's go we run on the train thing
that's not what the hell happens
yeah people exaggerate the numbers so
much now is it true that we are more
promiscuous today than we were before of
course
but we should be people are less shamed
for what they want to do
that goes for men and for women men are
out there doing more dirt women are as
well
but people talk like man she was on the
carousel
she was on she's like bro it reminds me
of how like
people like oh my god black man can't
stop being with white women meanwhile 88
of black dudes are married to white to
black women it's like people have a
perception and they think
you know what it says like it's like
perception is reality yeah so everyone
thinks it's way higher than it actually
is and it's just interesting to me that
he talks about like
uh this or that and i'ma criticize these
people and criticize this
but then we do a react video and he's
like i'm calling my lawyer you realize
how much of a fragile person he must be
to hear critiques and being like i'm
going to my lawyers you can't do this
you can't you know what he cried about
he said he's hurting my market value
because his critiques
are making people turn away from my
content it's like no your words
are making people turn away from your
content all i did was shine a spotlight
and add some commentary that's it
i can't make you look worse than you
make yourself look man you cannot be
mad at the fact that people are shining
light on what you're doing
when you want people to share yeah
someone's gonna share it to us
and we're gonna see it and we're gonna
shine some light on it yeah i mean
that's what you want
people share and as much as people are
going to turn away from your words
people are going to go on
onto it whatever you got to follow yeah
i cringe when i see this dude
and it just speaks to the fact that men
sometimes have so few access to mentors
that they end up falling for dudes like
this it speaks to how our society has
failed
to give uh men one partial role models
but also two
resources to learn how to deal with
relationships how to deal with women do
all this stuff it's like
if nobody's going to teach me the
streets are well whether it's pickup
artists whether it's
keys to the vip whether it's whatever it
is that's who they're going to learn
from
so i think this speaks to a larger
problem like managers not having good
resources of where they can get
good male role models and also solid
reasoning and ideas behind these things
and i think that's where you see this
sphere that's really popping right now
and it's like
profitable but it's honestly a lot of
it's a lot of garbage advice so
that's my take on all that
[Music]
i don't have to smear some more you said
what you said and then payments
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
you